if I were 27 and trying to publish my
first novel today I might be tempted to
shoot myself but I'm 67 and I have an
audience so I'm not especially worried
about my future in the book business but
um I think it's much harder to be a
young writer a writer starting out today
than it was when when I started out when
my first novel setting free the Bears
was published back in the late 60s here
was a novel wasn't even set in this
country was about a couple of Austrian
students and it had a historical section
which was easily half the length of the
novel about the Nazi and then Soviet
occupation of Vienna not a very American
subject I remember years later asking
the guy who published that first novel
if he would publish that novel if it
came across his desk today this was back
in the 90s um and my old friend and
editor and publisher
what I saw was he hesitated too long you
know he waited he thought oh god how do
I answer this one and then he said well
of course I would publish it today and I
said no you and I saw the hesitation and
he laughed and said no of course I
wouldn't very telling and I think it's
it's a lot tougher to be a first
novelist to be an unknown novelist today
than it was for me and so I I worry
about what's going to happen with those
good younger writers um but I don't
think the book is in any particular
peril I think the book is is going to
survive
you